hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Soder
we're gonna be checking out a video
toejam and earl back in the groove the
kickstarter trailer I have a confession
to make
yep I have definitely heard of toe jam
and earl you don't know who they are
for those that weren't born in the night
or we're i guess if you were born in the
90s you might not know for those that
were born in the eighties and enjoyed
the 90s era of gaming there was a
wonderful I think two games yes two
games toe jam and earl you basically
played as aliens trying to get home
because you had too much of a fun funky
tastic time interesting yeah
well I'm excited to see this back in the
groove
I actually like like I'll be just kind
of like I could listen to this funny got
like a Chili Peppers
to it something about watching this okay
I guess that was the end slate so what's
the gameplay like um it's it's really
[ __ ] hard to describe it's like it's
something on its own where it's you kind
of saw how there was like these
platforms in spate in space and you're
you basically walk around grabbing gifts
and food and avoiding enemies okay
you saw that door that they appeared in
the maybe here did at the very beginning
you're trying to find the elevator door
to go back up okay so it's kind of like
a puzzle platformer in a way do the
graphics look updated or is it honest I
didn't no idea what this is gonna be
like okay well is that what it was like
dis basically yeah but I will tell you
man like this trailer it's fun because
at first I'm like what is this am I
really gonna get into this I started
enjoying the song then I started
thinking I want to download this song
under way to remember all the lyrics to
this song and then it made me go I'm
gonna want to be toejam and Earl yeah
I'm going to want to play it yeah
especially because I'm so hooked on the
song and like watching them dance at the
end was really funny no I am like pulled
in it's so great because they didn't
freakin hold back at all if this trailer
with the 90s filled oh that was great
yeah like if you watch any like cartoon
from the 80 or like save Earth 8 90s
Saved by the Bell
anything die that sort of like squiggly
background where it's like a plain color
and yes there's like triangles and
random [ __ ] everywhere that's just that
that was our life I like it I really dig
it it looks like a fun [ __ ] like what
system was it on Genesis ok I would've
guessed Super Nintendo but ok no Genesis
makes more sense yeah was yeah
definitely Genesis ok oh I'm gonna get
yelled at if I'm wrong hold on let's not
get this wrong all right so due to
memory and not me looking it up on my
phone it is Genesis you are correct
yep because I was not out to prove you
wrong in no way shape or form did I know
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
dan has a gaming channel indeed pre-act
generally you should check it out it's a
really fun fun fun fun fun we having
some fun we're gonna go outside and eat
hot dog bug what I'm gonna eat a ton I
have a boy he's also my son that's what
you can call him he be haulin with a
wallet and holy dogs and oh my god or
how calm and oh my god for my back onto
my phone yep oh yeah you could follow us
on Instagram and Twitter
it's so [ __ ] awkward saying that
Facebook and Facebook Instagram Twitter
yes if I were saying that maybe we
should post something on her Facebook I
should probably start doing that more
yeah he's gonna post something if you
want a shout-out go respond to what he's
about to post make it interesting and
you earned yourself a shout-out if you
want to know what I said you got to go
here you got to go there if you want to
know what I said you got to go to mind
okay video complete ending joke laugh